What's up guys!
We are Pongfinity
We are back on our table tennis raft
to do lake trick shots part 2
Let's go!
So we used these to get here
Now let's see if we can play with them
Ready?
Yeah
The middle is the best part
Oh, i forgot that I had the backhand side
Paddle Master!
so cold!
I can't even see the table from here
Come on Emil!
Close
I don't recommend you to try this...
My whole ear is full of water
That's okay!
That was a good point,
One more...
ONE MORE?
This guy
He's been in there for half an hour, and he just wants more!
Okay!
If you haven't subscribed to our channel yet
please do it right now!
for more of this kind of content
Five in a row
well, no more
I didn't even see that it touched the table
Okay, that was sick!
Just hit it!
It was the best so far...
I think your racket was a bit wet
That looked so good
That looked so promising
Did it go on?
Yes it went!
Good job Miikka!
I think it's time to go fishing
Thank you!
You're welcome
That was hard
all right
it's time for the backflip table tennis shot
Yeah i think i need to
jump and hit it at the same time
I'm ready, I'm ready!
Aah i'm not ready!
Yeah just watch out for the edge...
Jackpot!
That was a good Jackpot
One of the best ones so far
Come on Michael!!
You got it!!
So close!
It was like ten centimeters
Come on Michael!
I've got so much water in my ears...
I can't even hear anything
You forgot the backflip...
It's not gonna work
I'm not gonna get it...
Do one more try, last try
One more try
Okay come on!
Okay that's enough
If you hit subscribe
I'll practice my water backflip
and one day we'll get this shot on
Picking up some balls
Otto is fishing
side change?
Side change?!
Yeah let's actually go for the side change
I'm not that fast
Again again!
So the sun has set, it's 10:30 p.m.
and we're ready to take a sauna
Okay let's pick the balls and go home
So if this video hit's thirty thousand likes
We'll be back next year with an even bigger even better...
Table tennis raft
Until next time!
If we hit one million subscribers by the end of 2019
I promise I'll get this shot on
Until next time!